[Musique]
bon je pensais pas qu'il y avait autant
de formations comme ça à dole ah oui
parce que ce matin on vous l'a pas dit
mais nous étions dans une boutique qui
s'appelle graines de talents
cette boutique a la particularité
d'exposer les savoir-faire des trois
lycées professionnels de dole regarder
[Musique]
tu es plus tôt
là
[Musique]
bonjour à la bonjour vous représentez le
lycée duhamel qu'est-ce que vous êtes
venu présenter comme discipline dans
cette boutique
alors on vient présenter donc une
formation qui est un peu
relativement récente qui s'appelle le
des aides mad diplôme national des
métiers d'art et du design c'est un
nouveau diplôme qui va remplacer les bts
arts appliqués l'idée c'était
d'uniformiser les diplômes avec le rough
caezar exactement c'est complètement en
corrélation avec le le mode de
recrutement du nouveau diplôme qui est
ouvert à tous les bacs
mais justement on va demander à laurine
bonjour lors vous vous veniez de quelle
section scientifique finalement faire du
design
il suffit d'avoir envie voilà c'est
exactement ça on va pouvoir montrer aux
gens ce qu'on fait est que c'est pas si
compliqué que ça et quand on est ici on
vient tenir la boutique pendant quelques
heures quelles sont les questions des
gens qui viennent voir il dit c'est pas
possible c'est pas vous qui l'avez fait
c'est vrai qu'ils sont surpris de ce
qu'on peut faire ici attendent pas mais
c'est un peu gratifiant aussi pour nous
parce que on a passé du temps dessus et
ça nous fait plaisir ce genre de
questions c'est valorisant de pouvoir
montrer qu'on est un professionnel
oui oui ac oui parce que on sait faire
des choses et on peut les montrer aux
gens et et qui découvre des choses qui
n'ont pas forcément l'habitude de voir
en temps normal je pense pas qu'on ait
l'habitude de voir des costumes crétois
antique sur 2 minimum
marion vous vous êtes venu à plusieurs
tenir la boutique et vous avez réalisé
des maquillages
oui on a réalisé des maquillages et des
pose de vernis avec modelage donc aux
clientes maquiller les gens mettre du
vernis ça vous met pas du tout la
pression
non non c'était super sympa surtout que
les clientes était super contente
on est ya eu un vrai échange on a pu
leur donner des conseils et c'est donc
c'était vraiment super contente
alors on voit là naît la pratique est un
vrai maquillage professionnel c'est pas
un maquillage de tous les jours ça c'est
quoi
non non c'est un maquillage soir c'est
un maquillage soir très prononcée très
artistique aussi
[Musique]
je
a dole les lycées professionnels les
jeunes qui viennent de là-bas quand on
les a chez nous c'est formidable pour
nous ça a été quand même quelque part
une révélation parce que si nous savions
que nous avions de très bons lycées
professionnels nous savions pas qu'ils
avaient une telle réputation à l'échelon
national
[Musique]
les établissements se sont entendus sur
les programmes pédagogiques pour qu'ils
entrent évidemment dans la formation à
laquelle ils sont soumis par l'académie
et ils se sont créé un calendrier au
cours duquel les trois lycées ont
présenté leurs travaux ensemble est
maintenant jusqu'à la fin de l'année
scolaire travaille de façon cyclique
dans ce lieu nous savons que c'est un
laboratoire c'est un cette année c'est
que dans le tente si c'est un échec
ça ne sera que de ma faute bien sûr que
j'espère que cet essai sera transformé
mais ça c'est l'histoire qui nous le
dira
si vous manquez d'idées pour vous
inscrire sur parcours sud je crois que
là vous avez eu un bon panel de
formations allaient nous on prend la
haute
ça